We want to look at
this pulley system.
We want to find out
what this force here
is, for example, with which
this block is being pulled.
Now we have two massless pulleys
here and two moving parts.
And one key component
of this problem
is to derive the
acceleration constraint.
How are we going to do that?
Well, we have to look
at this string here.
First of all, it's a
fixed string length.
And that will help us.
Ultimately, this is
just a distance that
connects all of these objects.
And if we eventually
differentiate that twice,
we get to an acceleration.
So the first thing
we're going to do
is to figure out what the
string length is to then derive
the acceleration condition.
Let's begin by first
identifying the fixed
length in this problem.
So we have a little
distance here.
We call it sb.
And we have a distance
here that's fixed, sa.
And we furthermore know
that this block here
is fixed to the ground.
And we can choose a
coordinate system origin.
Let's say we do that here.
We know that we have
the distance d here
to this little block.
The moving parts,
block 1 and block 2--
so we have to assign
position functions.
And actually this
one here is x1.
It goes up to here
because we want
to measure the string
length, ultimately,
and we know this portion here.
So we can subtract it.
And then of course we need also
x1, so that goes here-- x2.
So now we can tally
up the length.
Let's start with
this portion here.
That is d minus sa minus x2.
d minus sa minus x2.
And then we have a
half circle here, pi r.
And we know actually that there
is another half circle that's
going to come there, so we can
just write 2 pi r immediately.
And then we have this part here.
That one is x1 minus sb,
and then minus sa minus x2.
And then finally we
have this portion,
and that is x1
minus sb minus x2.
OK, so the next
step is that we need
to simplify this a little bit.
So we have one x1 and another
one here, 2x1 plus x2, x2,
x2-- actually 3-- minus 3x2.
And then we have all
sorts of consonants.
We have d, we have
sa, sb, the 2 pi r.
But, as you will see, if we
differentiate this out here,
that will actually
all fall away.
So we're going to make
our life easy and just
add a constant here.
And so we want to now do
the second derivative here
of our string length
with respect to time,
because these all
position functions.
So we can differentiate those.
What's important of course
here is this string length
is not changing with time.
So actually we know that
that derivative will be 0.
And we can just
write this up here
because x differentiated
twice is a.
So 2a1 minus 3a2.
And we immediately see from
that that a1 equals 3/2 a2.
So this is our
constraint condition
that we will need later.
For now, we need to continue
with setting up free body
diagrams of all four objects.
Let's start that with object 1.
What's acting on object 1?
Well, we have F here.
Why don't we just
write it as magnitude.
We have F, and then
we have here a tension
that goes to the
pulley B. That one
is different from the
tension in the string.
So we're going to call this TB.
And then we have object 2.
Oh, and of course, i hat
goes in this direction
because it follows the
motion of the object.
We have here kind
of the reverse.
Now we have a tension
of this string here
that's attached to
pulley A, but it's
different from this
string tension-- that's
a specific one-- TA.
And we also have a T
from the string here.
So we'll add a T. And then
if we look at pulley A,
we have two string
tensions, T and T.
And here we again have a TA.
And pulley B, TB,
and two T over here.
So that means we can write
down our equations of motions
using Newton's Second
Law, F equals ma.
And since this is just going
in the i hat direction,
we can just write down the four
equations following the four
free body diagrams here.
So we have F minus
TB equals m1 a1.
We have T plus TA equals m2 a2.
Then we have 2T
minus TA equals 0.
That is 0 because we're dealing
with two massless pulleys
there.
That means m is 0 and so
our acceleration term is 0.
So the m is 0 here.
And finally, we
have TB minus 2T.
No, not 2 pi-- 2T.
And that one is also 0 because
it is a massless pulley.
So here we have our
four equations of motion
that fully govern
this pulley system.
And we can use it
then, for example,
to find this pulling force here.
We know what TB is from the
equation down here-- so 2T.
We know what TA is.
It's also 2T.
And we can then
solve this for F.
The only sticky part is that
we have this a1 and a2 in here.
But for that, we derived this
constraint condition here.
So with that one, we
can fully solve this.
Otherwise, we would have
one too many unknowns.
Alternatively, if one were
to be interested in one
of these accelerations,
then this equation system
can also be solved for a1 or a2.